and greetings families faculty
distinguished guests autonomous robots
there's any of those first things first
I have to admit I feel seriously
under-qualified up here if I've tallied
this correctly we've got you know I'm
the only one who has not led a
university launched a company or won
eight Tony Awards and but I what I
submit that that's only because 127
hours
the musical hasn't yet made it to
Broadway yeah yeah you want to hear a
little snippet right I went hiking on my
own now I'm stuck here all alone no food
no water and my knife can't cut through
bone
qualified or not I am profoundly humbled
to join you for your commencement today
from this unparalleled place Carnegie
Mellon it's so good to be back this is
truly an extraordinary University the
home of buggy races the fence self
piloting SUV I heard it recently taught
itself to play the bagpipes actually I'm
sorry Michael but a Tartans got to do
what a Tartans got to do
we had in the following hours I had an
out-of-body experience where near-death
I left the canyon I walked down a
hallway I saw myself in a living room
and there was a little boy 3 or 4 years
old
blond hair the red polo shirt playing
with a truck
I saw myself interact with him scoop him
up with my hands with with my left hand
and a handless right arm his beautiful
brilliant blue eyes exploded and
wordlessly sank daddy let's play
sometime later the Sun rose up over the
desert and that dawn I was convinced
that I wouldn't see I came back and then
smiling a smile that embodied the love
of all of my closest relationships I
freed myself 10 years later that little
boy that I envisioned he's real we named
him Leo because the courageous little
lion who gave me the strength to get
through that night he's three years old
in fact he he's got several red polo
shirts and of course he loves playing
with trucks his love his smile is always
with me if I had to do it all over again
I would cut my other arm off in order to
get back to him and I'm pretty sure you
would do it too if you doubt for one
second actually that you would do it for
yourself ask what wouldn't you do to get
back to your closest loved ones because
the will to love says we're not just
here on this earth to enrich our own
lives
we're here to enrich the lives of others
thank you so much and congratulations
the class of 2013
thank you